The first national Olympics team to arrive in Japan...
...since the Games were postponed touched down on Tuesday.
Australia's softball squad waved to the media before making their way...
...to a nearly two-month training camp in central Japan.
Everyone on their team and their coaching staff has been vaccinated,...
...and officials say they'll be required to take a COVID-19 test...
...every day of their stay.
Before they left home, Australia's Olympic team leader Ian Chesterman...
...said the squad was comfortable with Japan's protocols...
...to protect them and locals.
And I think that these athletes...
...as well know that they have to take great responsibility...
...for their own behavior as well; they're committed to do that.
They're committed to not only look after themselves...
...but do the right thing by the Japanese population as well...
...and be ready for the Games.